Film Courage: Can we talk about the difference
in creating a fascinating protagonist for
film versus television?
Or maybe it’s the same?
Dan Calvisi: For film I think it’s going
to be affected by that closed ending because
their arc is going to arc over the course
of this 90 to 120 minute film or 90 to 110
page screenplay.
And then it’s going to end basically and
that’s where we’re going to leave the
character.
Whereas a TV protagonist, they have to be
able to go through various arcs over the course
of years, you know?
It may be for 10 seasons so there needs to
be the potential for that kind of growth.
Now you don’t need to know what’s going
to happen to this character to 10 seasons
but it would be good to know the basics of
what will happen like in the first two or
three seasons for example.
Film Courage: Any examples of characters you
can provide?
Dan Calvisi: Well if you give your protagonist
a lot of emotional baggage, then there’s
going to be a lot to unpack over time.
Something like Carrie from Homeland.
She is bipolar and she is reckless in her
behavior and she starts an affair with this
guy who she is supposed to be tracking that’s
a potential bad guy in Season One.
So she’s kind of a mess and so there’s
definitely going to be drama with her going
forward.
Or Don Draper from Mad Men.
He has the secret personality from the past
and he has this secret that he’s keeping…What
his true identity?
That’s always a risk to come out to destroy
him.
So if you keep some kind of element there,
some kind of Achilles' heel always there and
ready to destroy them, then you are going
to get a lot of seasons of material out of
that hero.
Film Courage: Let’s talk about for a feature
film because you said that there’s closure.
Can you give examples of an interesting protagonist?
It can be from a current film or not?
Dan Calvisi: Yes…a classic example of a
great character arc would be Indiana Jones
and Raiders of the Los Ark.
You know the first Indiana Jones film his
arc is to accept the supernatural.
He doesn’t believe in anything supernatural
or spiritual.
He doesn’t believe in God.
So when he gets this mission to find the Ark
of the Covenant, he just thinks it’s relic,
you know?
He doesn’t think it’s actually something
that could have any kind of power.
His final fruition of the Ark is when he respects,
let say “God’s Power,” and the power
of the Ark and he shuts his eyes and tells
Marion to shut her eyes once the Ark has been
open and the power of the Ark kills all the
bad guys but does not hurt him and Marion
because they’ve respected God and not looked
at the face of God.
So it’s not just him in a fight, you know?
You would think it’s an action movie, non-stop
action would be him fighting the head bad
guy.
It’s not at all and that’s what makes
it an interesting choice for the character
and to close the film it’s him respecting
the spiritual world.